ça
à l'automne 2017 le sénat examine le
premier budget du quinquennat d'emmanuel
macron le gouvernement s'apprête à
augmenter les taxes sur les carburants
au nom de la transition écologique dans
l'hémicycle les changes entre les
sénateurs et le ministre des comptes
publics va s'avérer prémonitoire parce
qu'on craint aujourd'hui et ça serait
absolument désastreux et celle écolo de
service qu'il dit c'est que on fasse
apparaître finalement la fiscalité
écologique comme un moyen de
rééquilibrer le budget de l'état point
c'est derrière la nouvelle vache à lait
l'état c'est la tonne carbone
nous ne voulons pas avoir un deuxième
phénomène des bonnets rouges
monsieur le ministre nous souhaitons
donc que vous attendiez que vous
accédiez aux demandes du sénat sur le
banc du gouvernement
gérald darmanin préfère ironiser je
viens vous parler des deux nouveaux
bonnets rouges et des nouvelles des
nouvelles et rouget et puis finalement
de la nouvelle jacquerie qui arrive à
monsieur dantec m'enfin hors de question
de reculer pour le gouvernement qui
maintient la hausse des taxes
un an plus tard presque jour pour jour
les gilet jaune sont dans la rue
[Applaudissements]
la france des ronds-points crie sa
colère
l'épisode est violent
il montre les limites d'une politique
environnementale sans contrepartie pour
les plus fragiles
[Musique]
yma
sa bomba
[Musique]
il
julie baumann a subi de plein fouet
l'augmentation du prix à la pompe
elle vit en lorraine à côté de lunéville
c'est là qu'elle et son mari ont pu
acheter une maison pour y élever leurs
deux enfants
loin de nancy la métropole et son réseau
de transports en commun
julie est auxiliaire de vie à domicile
elle s'occupe de personnes âgées ou
handicapées pas déjà mois pour faire du
domicile de personne à personne comme
j'ai un temps donné chaud obligés de
prendre leur voiture parce que des fois
je suis un peu plus excentré que
lunéville et bat pour les enfants on va
les chercher à l'école faut les amener
au sport et même pour aller au cours
faire des courses pardon je suis à 5 5
minutes 5 10 minutes
donc je obligé de prendre la voiture
alors voilà on arrive sur le lieu de
rassemblement avec le drapeau lorrain et
drapeaux français depuis le début du
mouvement les gilet jaune occupe ce rond
point à la sortie de lunéville nous les
sens c'est quelque chose d'important
pour aller travailler
c'est primordial sans essence sans
voiture on travaille pas on ne peut pas
aller bosser
alors tandis que c'est pas pour dire des
méchancetés sur quoi qui quiconque mais
les gens qui ont de l'argent se foutent
de payer l'essence 2e rôle dit des gens
qui gagnent dix mille europe aux 20000
euros par mois qu'est ce quelle
importance a peut-être qui seront
conscients de la pollution ça je suis
d'accord mais les sens c'est quand même
quelque chose qui est
je veux dire ça touche vraiment le
pourquoi là bas c'est pour ça que c'est
pour ça que ça a éclaté la france à
venir tous les jours c'est fait des
rencontres
donc il ya une amitié a vraiment un
groupe qui se soude
c'est très important et sont des dates
on est tous là pour la même chose
rapprocher et vit en moyenne
julie roule 100 km par mois elle perçoit
une indemnité kilométrique avec son
salaire mais pas de quoi couvrir la
hausse des prix déjà que ça faisait mal
avant mais depuis moment du gilet jaune
c'est vrai que à savoir qu'on donne la
plupart de notre argent à une taxe qu'on
ne sait même pas où elle va donc ça fait
vraiment un peu plus mal j'ai vu les
prix s'envoler et au fur et à mesure vue
qu'avant je faisais beaucoup plus de
kilomètres quand vous mettez deux pleins
par mois avoir d'autres plats ni ça me
coûte à peu près 200 euros 250 euros
donc vis ça commence à chiffrer
[Musique]
julie gagne environ 1000 euros par mois
son mari chauffeur routier multiplient
les heures sup pour ce foyer
les fins de mois sont difficiles on va
pas dire non plus que c'est
catastrophique parce que je veux dire on
est on travaille tous les deux on fait
attention à nos comptes on va pas
dépenser au delà mais on n'a pas de
sortir on va au restaurant on va pas au
cinéma
si je veux acheter une bricole pour les
enfants c'est tout est calculé vraiment
tous les mois
il ya un gros problème parce que je dis
on travaille tous les deux on mériterait
d'avoir quelque chose de se faire
plaisir et au final on on est toujours
en train de calculer les moins de
dépenses puisqu'il ya la cantine il ya
pas les impôts tout ça donc tout est
calculé par exemple ça fait cinq ans
qu'on n'est pas parti en vacances
entre 2017 et 2018 le prix du diesel a
grimpé de plus de 20%
plus de la moitié de cette augmentation
est due à la hausse des taxes
de quoi prendre à la gorge les ménages
modestes sans alternative à la voiture
ce qui coince en france aujourd'hui
c'est d'abord une situation sociale
c'est à dire on voit bien qu'on a en
france et c'est plus marquée que dans
d'autres pays européens
un reste à vivre qui baisse c'est à dire
les les gens qui travaillent mais qui
ont de petits salaires et qui se
retrouve aujourd'hui notamment aux
périurbain sont dans une situation avec
le coût du logement le coût du transport
ils ont l'impression de beaucoup
travailler et à la fin du mois d'août
quand même en difficulté
donc ça génère une grosse frustration
sociale effectivement la taxe carbone
est arrivé à un moment de flambée des
cours du pétrole et donc donc là il ya
eu le sentiment de ne plus pouvoir y
arriver si le mouvement des gilet jaune
a rapidement dépassé la question du
carburant
c'est pourtant bien elle qui a mis le
feu aux poudres la taxe carbone
introduite en france en 2014 à l'instar
d'autres pays européens comme la suède
l'irlande ou la grande bretagne
aussi appelée contribution climat
énergie
elle s'applique aux énergies fossiles
que nous consommons dans la vie
quotidienne carburants gaz ou fioul de
chauffage en fonction de la quantité de
co2 qu'elles émettent
le principe donner un prix au carbone
pour inciter progressivement les ménages
et les entreprises à se tourner vers des
énergies non polluantes en 2014
ce prix est fixé à 7 euros la tonne de
co2 en 2015
le législateur fixe une trajectoire pour
l'augmentation du prix du carbone à
mesure que se développeront les
alternatives aux énergies fossiles
ce prix qui sert de base de calcul au
montant de la taxe ainsi progresser
chaque année pour atteindre 30,5 euros
la tonne en 2010 est en 2018
sous l'impulsion de nicolas hulot le
gouvernement d' emmanuel macron décide
d'accélérer la montée en régime de la
taxation du carbone est d'aligner la
fiscalité du diesel sur celle de
l'essence d'ici la fin du quinquennat
lorsqu'arrive macron à la présidence
nicolas hulot ministre de l'écologie est
une deuxième trajectoire est défini
jusqu'à l'horizon 2022 et cette
trajectoire accélère la montée en régime
de la taxe carbone
la première année en 2018 le prix du
pétrole est encore proche de 40 dollars
le baril sur les marchés internationaux
donc l'augmentation passe à peu près
inaperçu et en 2019
on applique pour 2019 ce qui avait été
prévu dans la loi de finances un an
auparavant et là le prix du pétrole est
monté à 80 dollars le baril et donc la
pilule ne passe plus
l'augmentation des prix de l'énergie
nourri un sentiment d'injustice car la
taxe carbone à de nombreux trous dans la
raquette les secteurs très émetteurs de
co2 comme le transport aérien ou
maritime en sont exemptés quant aux
entreprises elles sont soumises au
système européen des quotas
des quantités de co2 qu'elles sont
autorisées à émettre et qu'elles peuvent
s'échanger entre elles sur un marché
avec un prix du carbone plus bas que
celui fixé pour les particuliers un
régime à deux vitesses auquel vient
s'ajouter une deuxième inégalités celle
entre les particuliers eux mêmes à court
terme la taxe carbone elle est anti
redistributive
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'elle
pèse plus en proportion sur les ménages
pauvres que sur les ménages riches et
donc à court terme il faut absolument
que une partie importante de du produit
de la taxe carbone soit redistribuée aux
citoyens avec une priorité sur les bas
revenus
une priorité qui n'a pas été celle des
gouvernements successifs en 2013
delphine batho va en faire l'expérience
alors ministre de l'environnement
elles critiquent publiquement les choix
budgétaires du gouvernement de françois
hollande
c'est un mauvais budget et moi je
souhaite que dans les jours qui viennent
nous puissions faire la démonstration qu
effectivement la volonté de faire de la
france la nation de l'excellence
environnementale la transition
énergétique ne sont pas des variables
d'ajustement
la sanction est immédiate delphine batho
et mise à la porte du gouvernement
cinq ans plus tard elle revient sur cet
épisode
une réunion d'arbitrage à matignon avec
le premier ministre et moi je conteste
le fait que la taxe carbone soit créée
pour financer le cic eux c'est à dire
qu'on va créer un impôt sur les ménages
pour que cet argent aille aux
entreprises et n'aille pas à l'écologie
et j'étais en désaccord avec cette cet
arbitrage a été exclu du gouvernement
dans l'est dans les heures qui ont suivi
et j'avais dit dans cette réunion
d'arbitrage au premier ministre mais
vous pouvez pas faire ça si vous faites
ça il n'y aura aucune
acceptation des français de ce
détournement de la fiscalité écologique
et il y aura une explosion sociale
elle s'est produite cinq ans après les
gouvernements successifs ont surfé sur
la baisse du prix du pétrole qui a rendu
indolore la taxe pour les ménages et
pour les entreprises qui la paient donc
pendant trois ans grâce à la baisse du
prix du pétrole
bercy a empoché empocher le jackpot il
était très content et comme de les
citoyens ne se rendait pas compte c'est
passé comme une lettre à la poste
jusqu'à l'explosion à l'automne 2010 8
l'existence de la taxe carbone est
désormais bien connue du grand public et
s'invite dans la discussion sur les
ronds-points si c'était l'argent allait
vraiment au point de vue écologique le
variable d'ajustement pour équilibrer le
budget
une variable d'ajustement pour remplir
les caisses de bercy
c'est aussi l'avis du sénat où la taxe
carbone a largement animé le débat
budgétaire
on sait très bien que les augmentations
de taxes ne vont pas la transition
écologique puisque la mission transition
écologique baisse cette année dans le
budget proposition des sénateurs
reverser une partie de l'argent de la
taxe aux collectivités locales pour
financer des projets de transition
énergétique mais leurs amendements se
heurte un avis défavorable du
gouvernement
on vous l'a dit l'année dernière ça ne
marchera pas ça ne sera pas acceptée il
fallait absolument au cas côté de cette
montée de la contribution climat énergie
on voit comment notamment les
territoires avaient les moyens d'assurer
cette transition
vous avez refusé nos propositions tous
les ans votée à l'unanimité par le sénat
aient voté encore l'unanimité cette fois
ci entendez les territoires on propose
en tous les cas à l'état de sortir enfin
de sa solitude ou de la situation de la
stratégie d'isolement dans laquelle il
le se réfugient pour l'instant c'est sur
cet amendement que pour la deuxième
année consécutive le sénat se prononce à
l'unanimité ya suffisamment de sujets
qui nous sépare pour ne pas regarder
entendre comprendre et met en oeuvre les
fois où on est sur une une demande
unanime
depuis 2015 ce sont les collectivités
locales qui sont en charge de réaliser
des projets de transition énergétique
dans les territoires on a besoin de 15 à
20 milliards par an d'investissements en
particulier dans ce qui devrait être la
priorité absolue aujourd'hui qui sont
les économies d'énergie
l'élimination des passoires thermiques
et en fait cette action-là de réduction
de la consommation d'énergie
elle est vertueuse pour le climat elle
est vertueuse pour le pouvoir d'achat
elle est vertueuse aussi pour l'activité
économique d'un secteur qui est
stratégique et celui du bâtiment et des
artisans du bâtiment coccyx doit y avoir
une priorité absolue d'investissement
c'est celle là
[Musique]
nous
à ploemeur dans le morbihan
claire et son mari ont acheté cette
maison des années 60 ils ont investi 40
mille euros pour transformer une
passoire thermique en une maison basse
consommation ont déclenché le l'insère
avec le petit écran qui est sur le côté
on peut régler la voilà la puissance la
chaleur des livres et c'est une chaleur
alors qu'ils se diffuse principalement
dans la pièce du bas mais en fait il ya
un conduit qui permet d'amener la
chaleur dans la cage d'escalier ou qui
permet de d'amener de la chaleur sur sur
les taches claires chauffe sa maison
avec des granulés de bois et n'utilise
sa chaudière au fuel quand chauffage
d'appoint mais pour conserver la chaleur
la clé c'est l'isolation les artisans
ont été obligés de faire tomber le
plâtre qui avait déjà pour remettre en
couche épaisse sur la laine de verre et
ensuite reposés du placo par dessus
à l'extérieur on a résolu l'ensemble des
murs donc en fait c'est du polystyrène
qui a été rajouté sur la façade est
ensuite y'a un enduit qui a été fait
pour redonner l'aspect qu'on souhaitait
pour savoir quels travaux réalisés
claire a bénéficié des conseils de
pierre le rouzic
cet ingénieur de formation travaille
pour l'agglomération de lorient c'est
super de voir le train ou les travaux
finis
déjà le rendu c'est super on a vraiment
garder le trouve le cachet de la maison
dans le sens où on n'a pas du tout
dénaturer d'un point de vue esthétique
bien qu'on en ait fait une bête de
course niveau isolation
le rôle de pierre sensibiliser les
ménages et les aider à financer leur
projet clair et son mari ont bénéficié
d'un crédit d'impôt pour faire leurs
travaux mais à lorient où vivent
beaucoup de foyers modestes
tous n'ont pas les moyens d'avancer de
l'argent en attendant une ristourne
fiscale
il ya beaucoup de maisons encore des
années 60 dans les années 60 on mettait
pas désolation dans les logements donc
c'est des logements aujourd'hui ou
le chauffage coûte cher sur des
bâtiments de ces années là en général on
est sur des bâtiments en parpaings
on ya pas d isolation dans les murs en
général il ya très peu d'isolation dans
la toiture
rénover nos maisons mieux isoler nos
appartements un levier immense pour
économiser de l'énergie en france
l'habitat représente plus de 40% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre c'est
une question sociale parce que c'est
forcément les personnes qui ont le moins
de moyens qui se retrouvent dans les
logements les plus vétustes quand on
n'arrive pas à payer les factures en fin
de mois et que le prix de l'énergie
augmentent et que l'on sans l'accord de
kousséri un petit peu plus peut pas
laisser les gens comme ça c'est la
solidarité il faut faire en sorte
d'améliorer le parc de logements pour ne
pas laisser les gens dans ces conditions
de vie si l'agglo de lorient a pris le
sujet à bras le corps c'est grâce à un
élu qui a fait de la rénovation
thermique son cheval de bataille
allez salut pierre fa si bien passé il y
a plus de dix ans jean paul aucher
ancien adjoint de la ville a fondé
l'agencé locale de l'énergie aujourd'hui
en france c'est vraiment les
collectivités qui font le travail
en termes de lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique notamment parce
que les investis sur des énergies
renouvelables sur des bâtiments de basse
consommation victimes l'élu a donc vu
d'un très bon oeil de l'amendement du
sénat qui demande qu'une fraction de la
taxe carbone soit fléchés vers les
collectivités
jean paul aucher a écrit à ses députés
pour qu'ils reprennent la proposition
des sénateurs à l'assemblée nationale
alors ça c'est courrier donc ça c'est un
mail des mails que j'ai envoyé un messie
députés le 17 décembre
alors pour l'instant j'ai eu des
réponses bas comme d'habitude on prend
bien être de votre et je cherche en pole
jeu
je transmets bien sûr au premier
ministre a demande voilà donc c'est un
peu c'est vraiment des alors il y en a
que toi qu'a répondu sur six déjà les
députés
et puis puisse évasif et puis ces fonds
fait tout bien et voilà ça c'est vrai
que c'est un peu irritant à terme
pourrait à la fois un territoire
agricole littoral l'assuré son mari non
on risque de la subir donc on a besoin
vraiment d'être l'acteur et de dettes
refinancées aussi pour ça parce que
c'est sa part est un élément important
de notre lutte
[Musique]
moi je suis convaincu que l'argent le
mieux utilisé en france reste l'argent
qui est investi dans les territoires
l'erreur de hollande est l'erreur de
macron derrière c'est quand même de
baisser la capacité d'investissement des
territoires et ça s'est vu sur l'emploi
on a besoin de gens qui vont voir des
ménages modestes en leur disant vous
avez des droits de pour modifier vos
chaudière changer vos fenêtres
est ce que vous les connaissez c'est
compliqué quand les crédits d'impôts les
remboursements donc on a besoin de gens
qui explique toute cette animation là
aujourd'hui n'est pas financé c'est le
socle
si on veux redire les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre
[Musique]
à 2000 km de lorient loin des
préoccupations locales katowice en
pologne accueille la conférence
internationale sur le climat
près de 200 pays doivent s'engager pour
tenir les promesses de l'accord de paris
et maintenir l'augmentation de la
températures mondiales en dessous de
deux degrés la coop il ya un côté
communauté qui se déplace à travers le
monde le world climate circus tour c'est
vrai que ça existe et c'est aussi une
question qu'à mon avis sur la table
maintenant est ce que cette bulle qu'est
la coop est totalement en prise avec
toutes les dynamiques y compris sur les
questions climatiques
je pense de plus en plus qu' une partie
des décisions clés ne se prennent pas à
la coop même si la coop ça ça reste
quand même le salon international du
climat donc pour rencontrer beaucoup de
monde dans un temps court donc
finalement faire moins de transport
économiser du co2 ça reste une bonne
opportunité
le sénateur de loire atlantique ronan
dantec préside également une ong
environnementale klein chaîne ce en
pleine crise des gilet jaune
la coop 24 a les yeux rivés vers la
france
[Musique]
la solution avec les revendications
déchets des gens se trouvent précisément
plus de dynamisme derrière ces éléments
de langage
l'incertitude est palpable après
plusieurs week-ends de violence
emmanuel macron doit s'exprimer dans la
soirée à la télévision augmente le
pouvoir d'achat fort d'aller chercher de
l'argent quelque part
ça ne marche pas
ont comme moi je ne sais pas quand je
sais pas ou alors on leur point
d'équilibré
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
en écho au mouvement de gilet jaune le
thème de la justice sociale s'invite au
coeur des débats de la coop 24 comme
dans cette réunion de parlementaires du
monde entier tara puma réveiller les
passages bang rouler ses loups pour
surmonter le citoyen lambda qui paient
leur place et des volailles et redoubler
qui va se produire l'original
[Musique]
je
alors vendeurs dantec iam frentzen
attend cette coop
elle va dire ça elle va dire sans
justice sociale il n'y aura pas de
transition
or on ne répondra pas aux défis
climatiques le problème c'est que
derrière si on répond pas aux défis
climatiques c'est quand même aller à les
plus défavorisés des ménages les plus
modestes qui paieront le prix le plus
fort donc il faut quand même qu'on
essaye d'y arriver et c'est pour ça
qu'on est là mais certains pays traînent
des pieds dans la lutte contre le
réchauffement
dans ce contexte la situation en france
inquiète ses partenaires
c'est très non je pense que c'est c'est
pas génial d'être à la tête et pour les
autres pays non plus non non non si
macro parce que ma projets venus écouter
à abonde quand il a fait un grand
discours sur
championne le climat est maintenant
c'est quelque chose très très défensif
ça c'est dangereux et qu'au nous avons
eu ce débat en allemagne quand nous
avons instauré une taxe écologique
beaucoup de résistance mais nous avons
veillé à bien expliquer aux gens que
tout ce que nous percevions bien cette
taxe nous allions immédiatement le
réinvestir non pas pour boucher les
trous dans la caisse mais pour les
politiques sociales et les retraites
on ne peut pas donner l'impression à
ceux qui sont en bas de l'échelle
sociale qu'ils payent la facture pour
une crise climatique dont ils sont
souvent les moins responsables ma crise
en asie
[Musique]
il est un pays en europe qui a su
concilier fiscalité écologique et
politique sociale la suède taxes le co2
120 euros la tonne un record dans le
monde en l'espace d'une génération
les suédois ont abandonné le fioul pour
se chauffer tous ces tuyaux en même
l'eau jusque dans les radiateurs de la
maison et apporte aussi l'eau chaude
pour la cuisine et la salle de bain
comme une majorité de suédois fredrick
lindgren a remplacé sa chaudière par une
pompe à chaleur géothermique
cela suffit amplement à chauffer notre
maison sauf peut-être un ou deux jours
vraiment trop froid dans l'année où nous
consommerons un peu d'électricité en
plus c'est un investissement devenue
rentable à cause de la hausse des taxes
sur le fioul domestique malgré ses
hivers rigoureux
la suède possède aujourd'hui loto
d'émissions de co2 par habitant le plus
bas d'europe
un coup et nous avons eu un débat
équilibré en sus de cash
je trouve que la transition s'est
effectuée en douceur les gens
comprennent que l'on doit faire quelque
chose qu'il faut un changement
une transition qui ne s'est pas fait
sans contrepartie introduite en 1991 la
taxe carbone suédoise a donné lieu
notamment à une baisse de l'impôt sur le
revenu
la suède veut atteindre la neutralité
carbone en 2045
[Musique]
la taxe carbone a été beaucoup mieux
perçu parce que elle n'était que l'une
des composantes d'une réforme fiscale
générale qui a été discuté pendant deux
ans et qui a fait l'objet d'un consensus
non pas totale il est très rare qu'on
ait un consensus total en matière
fiscale mais d'inde large consensus au
sein des forces politiques et les
syndicats traditionnels en suède en
france
le processus est interrompue devant la
levée de boucliers le gouvernement a
émis un moratoire sur l'augmentation
prévue de la taxe carbone s'agit-il
d'une occasion manquée pour le climat
c'est cet axe était apparu finalement
comme un élément de redistribution
elle aurait été totalement accepté et on
ne serait pas avec une perte de recettes
sur les prochaines années puisque
maintenant bloqué dans sa progression
que plusieurs dizaines de milliards
d'euros
c'est plusieurs dizaines de milliards
d'euros qui vont manquer suite à ce
blocage tout ça parce que l'état n'a pas
voulu remettre 1 ou 2 milliards en
redistribution
bravo merci à la fin de l'histoire ça
fait quand même beaucoup d'un gros trou
dans la caisse la décision de d'annuler
la hausse de taxe carbone si vous voulez
elles augurent d'une phase 2
de recul sur
les politiques climatiques nicolas
sarkozy qui avait eu la formule après le
grenelle de l'environnement
l'environnement ça commence à bien faire
on est un peu dans la même chose
[Musique]
le moratoire sur la taxe carbone
pourrait ralentir les efforts de la
france dans sa lutte contre les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre mais
la révolte des gilet jaune montrent que
la transition vers une société plus
verts ne se fera pas sans davantage de
justice sociale du manque les comprends
pas la jouer ça on est les premiers
colons
le problème
on a très bien compris qu il faut à nier
ne vibre jusqu'à la fin du mois et
politiques si on a des sous mais qu'on
respire pas c'est pas possible on est
les premiers écolos faut arrêter de nous
faire passer pour des gros pollueurs la
taxe carburant c'était la taxe de trop
mais bien sûr qu'on a envie de laisser
une planète propre à nos gars sont qu'on
a envie de montrer quelque chose de
l'union devront évidemment qu'on y croie
à l'écologie d'ici 2030 notre pays veut
réduire de 40 % sa consommation
d'énergie fossile
un défi environnemental et démocratique
afin que l'objectif d'une transition
juste tels que la préconisent la corde
paris devienne une réalité
[Musique]
map etc